hey everyone how's it going my name's
miyuko and
welcome back to my channel we're doing
something a little bit different today
we are gonna code i was sent this thing
called
lumi cube which is an led cube kit
run on raspberry pi there was a
kickstarter for this recently and they
were kind enough to send me one
i played around with it a little bit
when i first got it but i haven't really
done a whole lot
yet but what i do know is that this
thing is super fun to code on
so i thought i would do that together
with y'all today i'm very
unskilled
when it comes to writing i believe it's
python is it python i think it's python
i thought
it might be fun possibly funny uh for
y'all to watch me make sense of this
thing
and play with it basically i rarely
actually ever had chances to actually
play with code because most of the time
like 99
of my coding has been for work or for a
job
so this is me just just playing kind of
and probably inevitably getting really
frustrated at this thing
but i think it'll be a fun time how will
it go i don't know
maybe we can have like a little montage
of
the summation of all the experiences
right here
how do you do this what is what is my
code even doing
[Music]
coding is hard yes
[Laughter]
poo yeah so that's how it goes so if
you're interested stick around
and before we get started i want to say
thank you to the sponsor of today's
video dot
tech okay so this statistic boggles my
mind but did you know that only 47
of public high schools in the united
states teach computer science
which makes sense like i wasn't offered
computer science at my high school i
learned it in college
so that's just one said statistic but
i'm sure you all know that access to
computer science and tech education is
extremely limited
and it's especially so for young women
and students from marginalized
communities today so what's really cool
about today's sponsorship is that
tech domains is trying to do something
about this so they're going to donate
not 10 not 50 but a hundred percent of
their sales proceeds to code.org to help
change this which like 100 percent like
that's
that's that's freaking wild my own
journey into tech started with just
changing some lines of css in what we
call zynga
from back in the day but i didn't really
start coding until i was in college
and that's when i took my intro to
computer science class and i learned
java for the first time
and the rest is kind of history i've
just been super lucky to find computer
science my university and have been
really lucky to kind of been exposed to
computer science and role models
but if you also feel the same way that
everyone deserves to follow their
passion in tech
then go visit go.tech mayuko to learn
more and know how you can make a
difference
i have a tech domain for my honko
academy and so
yeah it's a really good domain service
and i recommend you get one too thank
you to dot tech for sponsoring and i
appreciate you for trying to make a
difference
okay so so far the only thing that i've
really kind of done with this project is
to make like a little cherry tomato
on all three sides isn't it cute because
my goal is to make a pomodoro timer
i don't really know what it's going to
look like or how it's going to work
but we're going to try it and so far i
just wanted to understand how the leds
work so
i made a cherry tomato using this here
coat
this is gonna be interesting because i
don't really know what i'm doing so
let's go okay so i think the first thing
that i did was
um last time i was also on my way of
doing this
and so i made like a little pseudo code
thingy
as you can tell it says do stuff and i
also have like a little timer function
so let's see how this works i think all
i really needed to do was
like this is pretty close already uh
because this
itself i have our red white and green
and so here's the top panel here's the
left panel and here's the right panel
and i have all of these be the same and
it's basically a matrix representation
of the leds and then i just set
panel left right top so pretty
easy there so palm duration is 25 in
minutes
seconds in a minute 60 so duration is
palm duration time seconds in a minute
so then time for each row i think yeah i
think that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
have each row
build up i guess to a cherry tomato
probably
so like it's just gonna like
go to the next thing and then at the max
time it's gonna be the max
okay so then if i press start here oh
oh i think there's a oh
there's a unexpected indent i believe
where's that where
how do you do this oh i think this is
working
what is what is my code even doing okay
i should have read this line
so seven zero is here seven seven is
here so this is zero
zero this corner okay
okay okay okay
will it run if i indent it like this too
please don't complain to me
even yeah okay that works okay so i want
to fill from the bottom
upwards so this is the row that we're
gonna look at first
zero zero will be black
oh goodness is gonna be manual as heck
isn't it zero
one two three four five six o'clock
okay let's try it
haha i did that
i did that this is gonna be manual as
heck
is this not how you do elsif's in python
if yes but i need an else if
alif l l if
alif alif we can go with elif that
sounds like a name
it sounds like mystical creature name
stop and start
i think there is an issue didn't i
fix things though
cody is hard my apologies i complain a
lot when i
when i uh code honestly i'm not sorry
coding
coding be like this though we all
watching this are probably
maybe more annoyed at me than anything
else because you probably know how to do
this and i don't
so hope you'll at least stay for the
entertainment
this is this is big time mucho being
exposed
oh look oh
watch magic
yes
who says that coding can't be fun coding
is hard
um i brought the rwg up and then i
changed
i updated some of these things okay
so that should be the colors now i gotta
go whoop
let's see how quickly i can do some
manual tasks
ready ready ready go
oh i messed up sometimes coding is not
about how quickly you can type
and it's about the quality of the
keystrokes
and the quality of the thoughts that
come out of your brain okay
once this is done once i finish this
kind of manual labor thing which
you know it's definitely kind of a brute
force solution but it's fine
um then it'll just work
i'll it'll be over it's over
but what if we don't want it to be over
no frankly i want it to be over
that's the truth okay ready moment of
truth fam
eh
oh my gosh
oh almost
oh wait but that's literally just
one side it's not all sides oh
heck the right all the different panels
are different
x y and z coordinates
the other way i could go about doing it
is figure out how to blink it first
like i basically want it to do like the
whole like
okay we're on this one blink blink blink
blink and then it goes to this one blink
blink blink blink
blink blink blink blink disco clock
does clock no that's just that just
scrolls the time
oh but i could do that at the end
cube.scrolltext
yo because
on my twitch streams whenever we'd
finish a palm it would say yo
yo okay let's try it
invalid syntax file main oh heck
oh because there's no such thing as
brackets in
python come on
yes
can i make it play sounds that would be
annoying though if every minute it made
a sound
all right ready here's what we've all
been waiting
for yo
nice nice nice
now what i wanted to see if the blinky
thing could work
how would that work okay so it'd
basically be
time duration in seconds would go up by
0.5
and then every 0.5
the feeling when you haven't coded in a
long time in your brain just like don't
doesn't remember
how to speak in computer um so this one
will be
blank bottom row and then like
blink off
bottom row i feel like this is gonna go
poorly
it's everything's gonna blink start
[Music]
it's not blinking off
i think just my math is wrong print
duration
in seconds divided by time for each row
okay this should work
[Music]
it's doing it it's doing it it is
freaking doing it so how do i make it
stay
after it gets to the next thing
so then when it hits seven i just need
it to be on forever
oh less than or equal to seven or
greater greater than or equal to seven
that's
the bugs and stay yes
prince statements are so helpful my gosh
that was terrifying
yeah i know what i'm doing i know what
i'm doing
okay wow i'm writing a lot of code
without testing
that's a little scary but i'm okay with
it
oh my goodness ready ready
[Music]
blink blink blink blink
blink link link
link blink link blink
blink blink blink
blink blink blink blink
yo hey that looks so good
i wonder if it's going to be 25 minutes
then maybe i should actually just make
it every second
every it'll it'll just be like this
and we make it like an even number so 8
times
4 is 32. that's that's it ready demo
this is an entire 25 minute palm though
isn't that
cute i think that's really cute
i think that's super duper cute but
that's just me
i also made this and i'm pretty proud of
it so hey
thank you so much for watching today's
video i hope you enjoyed it or at least
that you were a little bit entertained
by
my coding abilities or lack thereof i
know i'm not the fastest coder
but i still had fun anyways if you'd
like to see more videos like this
code along with me code with me watch my
yuko make so many silly mistakes in
python
videos then let me know in the comments
down below as always don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
for more videos on tech career and life
and i'll see you next time
bye